[Music]
hey guys it's me jasmine fall is
creeping up on us and we are ready for
those fall seasonal eats and drinks
today katie kelly and i have pulled some
of our favorite fall cocktails and
appetizer pairings and we're going to
show you how to make them let's drink
so what i've chosen is a buttered rum
paired with a monte cristo rose bite i
love an easy a quick and really pretty
appetizer because you know you got to
get the pictures i have started here
with a store-bought puff pastry and
we're just going to roll this out until
it's 12 inches so we're going to cut
them into strips
about an inch and a half
wide so on the puff pastry strips i am
going to brush on a good amount of
raspberry jam i usually will probably
put around a teaspoon and a half two
teaspoons next we're gonna lay down the
ham so it's peeking over the puff pastry
just a little bit like that i cut my ham
so that they look kind of like half
moons it's more visually appealing okay
so now that our ham is lined up like
this we're going to fold the bottom of
the puff pastry so that the jam doesn't
spill out when it's baking we are going
to sprinkle on some cheese of course if
you love cheese add as much as you want
the more you add the harder it is to
roll up finally it's time to roll up the
puff pastry start with the side closest
to you and just roll it away into a
tight spiral and there you have it look
it's so cute doesn't it look like a rose
we are just going to put this on a
baking sheet i'm going to do this with
the rest of my puff pastry strips and
then once i have filled it up i'm going
to brush them all with egg wash and then
pop them in the oven and while they're
baking it's time to make our drinks so
for our cocktail i have chosen buttered
rum it's so good it will pair so well
with the monte cristo bites you've got
sweetness
i just really like a sweet drink
actually some people find the idea of
buttered rum to be a little strange
because you know there's butter in your
drink and it's all warm and kind of
feels like you're drinking butter but
hey you know they have bulletproof
coffee
people love that stuff so to my butter
i'm adding pumpkin spice measure out one
teaspoon then we're gonna add in our
brown sugar
vanilla extract
and just a pinch of salt another thing i
like about this drink is that you can
make this mixture make a huge batch and
just use it whenever you want you don't
have to use it right away you want soft
butter if you have cold butter and it's
all hard you're not going to be able to
mix it i'm excited to get alcohol in my
body okay grab yourself a heat proof mug
i chose this one it kind of reminded me
of harry potter all right i'm adding a
couple tablespoons of my butter mixture
in there
now i have some hot water i'm going to
pour it over my butter mixture now
you're going to mix it all up until all
the butter is dissolved okay now it's
time to add in the alcohol
my favorite part so i'm going to add in
one ounce of rum
it smells strong now we're going to top
this with some whipped cream
and some freshly ground nutmeg okay this
looks good i'm pretty happy with it i'm
going to go grab the appetizers and then
also see what katie and kelly think
about it
this looks
so good jasmine it smells so good
that nutmeg on top like you get the
little bit of rum you get the
buttery-ness and you get that sweet like
you've got to do the whip and then you
get the rum burning down the rum feels
good yeah yeah i guess we should try
your
appetizer yes
these are beautiful
that's awesome i really love the grier
in here with the jam it really is a nice
pairing yeah because there's just like a
little bit of sweet but there's a lot of
salty which is nice like to pair with
this drink i'm not gonna lie one of my
favorite parts about this is just the
puff pastry final approval yes good yes
amazing he's like if i came to your
party we'd still be friends yay
okay then we'll see if we'll still be
friends with kelly because you're next
all right let's go more drinks
all right it is my turn and i'm making a
spice fig margarita because i love
tequila and also to pair with that i'm
making a fig and brie bite all right to
get started i have some frozen puff
pastry that i have thawed out and it's
on a floured surface we're gonna roll it
out a little bit and then cut it into
two by two inch squares
i have my cute little puff pastry
squares and i also have a non-stick mini
muffin pan if you don't have a non-stick
make sure you spray it with some
nonstick spray but we're just going to
take our cute little square and stuff it
in there it doesn't really matter what
it looks like we're going for rustic
then i'm going to add a little bit of
fig jam a piece of brie and some
crumbled up bacon and that is it it's so
easy it's so simple i'm going to keep
doing this and then bake them up now i'm
just going to brush some egg wash on
that puff pastry to get it really golden
brown in the oven an egg wash is just
one egg mixed with a tablespoon of water
all right i'm gonna pop these in a 400
degree oven for about 10 to 12 minutes
just until they're golden brown and
while they're baking i'm gonna get out
that tequila and make a margarita all
right so for my cocktail i am making a
spiced fig margarita i love margaritas
but they remind me of summer so i'm
gonna add some warming spices
and flavors to kind of make it more fall
aside i don't know if that's a word but
it sounds good first i'm gonna do is rim
my cocktail glass with some lemon juice
and then i'm just gonna dip it in some
cinnamon sugar normally a margarita has
salt but we're
gonna try it with some cinnamon sugar
and next i'm gonna make a cheaters
simple syrup this way we don't have to
make a simple syrup from scratch and get
pots and pans out and turn the stove on
all right i'm just going to add a little
bit of fig jam some water
and a pinch of cinnamon
stir it together and then i'm just going
to microwave this for about 15 to 20
seconds all right i'm just going to add
a little bit of lemon juice normally you
use lime juice in a margarita but i
think the lemon pear is a little bit
nicer with the fig and i'm going to add
one and a half ounces of tequila so you
might be wondering why i'm not putting
ice in this is what is called a dry
shake we're going to shake all that
stuff together without the ice so it
really gets to meld together first
what's going on in your head when you're
shaking
nothing
oh
i'm just thinking how much longer until
i can open this and drink it now i'm
gonna add the ice
okay add a little more ice to your
cocktail glass
look at that color isn't that pretty it
kind of looks like apple cider spice
apple cider but there's tequila in there
and i'm gonna keep it super simple and
garnish with a cinnamon stick and that's
it i'm gonna go get my appetizer grab
katie and jasmine and see what they
think
all right here is my fall aside
margarita and some appetizers let me
know what you think
that's yummy this is delicious the
cinnamon sugar around the glass is way
better than salt i agree i don't think
i'm ever gonna do a salt room again
let's try the appetizer and see if it
pairs well
you put a little thyme sprig on top and
that's a really nice like herbiness with
a sweet fig that's actually a bomb
pairing oh wow i haven't heard that in a
while it's da bomb we are going to get
back to the sweet train with a dessert
and a very strong cocktail
i hope you're ready jasmine is just
sugar i can handle it i just want it
really sweet
so when i think of fall i think of
s'mores i think of camping i think of
five well i don't think of camping at
fault what i want to make is a s'mores
bark with a s'mores cocktail but it's
basically a white russian so basically
you're just gonna take a bunch of graham
crackers run them through a food
processor or you can put them in a
ziploc bag and crush it up with a
rolling pin and then you're going to
take a bunch of butter cause butter's
the best
mix in all that melted butter into our
graham crackers so we just want to mix
this up till it's that wet sand texture
so we're gonna take a baking sheet lined
with some parchment paper and
we'll just
pour out all our graham crackers try to
pack it down
you can take a spoon you can take the
base of a measuring cup what i also like
about barks is they're super easy to
whip up and you can make a ton of them
and they're great gifts they're not like
too expensive and now we're gonna take i
like to use mini marshmallows you can
definitely use normal sized ones but i
don't i think they distribute the mallow
better so now we're gonna take this put
it in the oven at 350 degrees for about
10 minutes just until it starts getting
like a little little golden brown on the
tops that's perfect and then take it out
all right our marshmallows are roasted
and now it is time to just quickly throw
the rest of this together we're going to
go with the semi-sweet chocolate chips
that we've melted and i'm just going to
pour this right over the top and then
make a smooth even layer as even as
possible finish it off with some more
marshmallows a little bit of graham
crackers and then i love to do a little
chocolate drizzle over the top i think
it just makes it look fancy okay so our
s'mores bark is in the freezer it is now
time to make our s'mores cocktail so to
get started we're gonna dip this in just
some melted chocolate and then we're
gonna dip that into our graham cracker
so you can just use some leftover when
you make your bark
oh how cute
you're gonna
line the cup with just an abstract art
version of more chocolate syrup now
we're going to shake some booze we're
going to do an ounce of chocolate corn
and then we're going to do a half an
ounce of vanilla vodka this is a huge
bottle of vodka that they've uh it's
massive and then we'll add some ice to
this
put our cap on we're gonna shake
we'll add in some ice to our glass we'll
pour in our
liquor and then we add heavy cream and
then i'm gonna add a little garnish it's
some toasted marshmallows we just
broiled those in the oven and that is a
s'mores cocktail i'm gonna go get my
bark break it into pieces and we're
gonna do a taste test
now before you drink your drink you have
to mix it
[Music]
oh
it's like an adult s'more it's really
strong would you like to try dessert yes
i think this is the perfect consistency
this is amazing
i love the ratio of graham cracker to
marshmallow to chocolate it's really
good cheers guys thank you so much for
watching let us know in the comments
what cocktails or just drinks you like
to make in the fall and food until next
time
you are going to town on that he's
calling me out but i'm really enjoying
it
[Music]
[Music]
you